hello everybody what's up welcome to
their beautiful Monday I'm here with my
beautiful friend Chris waters thanks
Peter and you kind all a man thanks
this is megabit where I play old games
with old friends and today we are
playing Jurassic Park on the Genesis yes
I had almost no experience at this game
Chris waters you love this I have some
powerful nostalgia for this game I was
so psyched for this Jurassic Park was
like one of the first movies I ever like
one of them first like live-action
movies ever saw in the theater my
parents were like not gonna take movies
so I went a super end of the movie the
game was coming out I like saved up my
money I bought it I invited my friends
over I straight like I put the cartridge
in the Genesis and draped a tissue over
it to do like a romantic reveal for them
we were also into dressing we were
telling you that well let's show them
what you and your friend saw we did it's
a dinosaur III didn't see Jurassic Park
in theaters my parents were not having
that so I had to wait for the home
release go to his sleepover to watch it
get the VHS in there and I was like I
know why they don't want me to see this
mild to serious peril oh the greatest
thing about this game though which was
so surprising to me it was this you can
play as the scientist guy or the friggin
dinosaur but it does I don't animation
yeah so this is the this is the Raptor
like voguing for the camera I guess like
what's up sup and then grant just
looking terrified yeah this is Martina
doing the twist all right we should we
start with let's start with Grant at
least alright we'll start with Grant do
you want any codes do any passwords for
like infinite ammo or anything because
we got them let's say let's uh let's do
some passwords later we maybe we'll do a
little level skipping cuz the game is
not very easy
no from watching you playing from the
few minutes I've played there's a whole
lot of sort of off-screen stuff to
explore and it's not really clear where
you're supposed to go look at that
Oh t-rex is messing up that tiny
chocolate truck yeah there's a there's a
lot of like you kind of got to know the
levels and that might
really is strong with the first few
levels then there's this raft level
we'll get there it is dangerous it's no
good
but dinosaurs are on the loose
throughout the island so we're gonna
make our way through the jungle through
the power station and the Jurassic Park
games that came out for the Genesis and
Super Nintendo were actually very
different
yeah I'm intending one was like a
top-down sort of it not really an RPG
but it has some RPG elements yeah it
looks like the what's that link game the
still the link to the past yeah that one
yeah you know that one that's like super
famous yeah you know yeah and then they
came up with a sequel for this one for
Genesis which looks nearly identical we
called rampage edition but apparently
it's got more features a little bit
smoother a little bit smoother yeah
you'll see so there's like a little bit
of herky-jerky stuff going on smirking
jerk but I just down that Dilophosaurus
but you'll notice it's still breathing
these are tranquilizer darts I guess the
Triceratops earlier and now there's
pterodactyls to wrangle with and the ooh
that's all the time he gets injured uhmm
so I'm here to avoid falling on spike
I'm gonna give you guys some background
on the Dilophosaurus about 4 feet tall
the Dilophosaurus is spotted like an owl
yeah with a brilliantly colored crest
that fans out around its neck when
aroused oh hi
what does it say about spitting
projectile vomit okay seemingly playful
the kangaroo like carnivore makes a
curious hooting sound before its deadly
attack it kills by spitting on its
victims from as far as 20 feet away with
a lethal venom that blinds and paralyzes
its prey so to learn injury to owl
references in that description
apparently it's owl like yeah that looks
like an owl to you I don't know was
they've been looking at but it doesn't
do the gentle hooting Brad yeah it's
just right in shrieking alright get over
yeah see like his is like rope climbing
savvy not so good
come over here so I can yeah he is just
hurling those turds Amanda they're not
tears but they kind of look like turds
yeah their mouth hurts and then he makes
full swishing easy
those little copies are delightful when
you play as the Raptor which will do
shortly the copy short for pro comps are
gone but pro Compsognathus the
Compsognathus okay a pint-sized but
powerful animal whose bulldog like grip
with its jaws can bring down far larger
beasts and is especially effective on
you oh not if you get tranq first sucka
good night sweet copy prints disappoint
of Mary Kish isn't here cuz she was the
most enthusiastic super stoked about
this game but she's like taking the day
off to like yeah you know be healthy and
be relaxed type human in this world
hello what's up buddy you're friendly
right Oh looks like an old man so you
can like climb on these vines but this
like inevitably happens right here you
can climb all the way across and it's
always been that way and I spent so many
hours just like trying to like yeah
that's a strange point but it doesn't
happen so we have to go down and around
and sometimes it looked a game like this
is like you're not sure if they did that
on purpose right might have done it to
like make me do that spike jump and like
go those around or a flaw yeah it's like
didn't quite match up there like
environment tiles or whatever that you
know need the you need for the
continuity of that friggin thing but is
a little little okay okay he's a little
floaty
oh no no go down I don't want to be here
oh man Oh triple tab them just to be
sure okay all right so this really he's
your friend he's not he's not I mean
he's my friend but he's also in the way
I need to jump across this gap so you're
gonna deter Grenada so I'm gonna throw a
grenade at two grenades actually because
he's really big he's like fine good get
it I'm out of here low you'll be rude
about it all right that was possibly the
best I've ever done on that one more
good job this game is like a different a
few different you know you can obviously
play as a raptor and dr. grant yeah but
you're saying something about like a
raft level and don't you also get to
write a Jeep at one point maybe have you
ever beaten this I'm not sure if I
actually beat this game Peter this is
one of those games that like I totally
own but maybe I did not actually beat
all right some of the Power Station now
I'm gonna meet up with it a good friend
of mine you seem kind of out of frame
over there I'll pick up these concussion
grenades tell me this difficult boom ah
nope
wait daughter after I'm gonna hit him
with my deluxe tranq darts and then he's
kind of twitch is there it has like a
real bad seizure and I'm on my way
oh it's probably use it to lights for
this I have a charge as a prey so I can
like the horse but it's like reliable is
well it takes a second to charge up and
it's range is limited so I prefer the
tranq darts remember possible you know
watching this in action it kinda reminds
me of alien 3 yo Genesis oh yeah you
ever play that no like the the sort of
stunted jerky animation and a level
design both kinda remind me of that game
Oh turded fart cool
just watch this natural dis dinosaur on
his natural habitat shaking insistently
oh god why don't I just shoot it it's
wait car is hot water Jesus this is
terrible
okay I get my hat on straight
so like Jurassic Park in general Peter
is obviously a huge cultural phenomenon
or was in that yeah yeah were you were
you like big on the Dino train at that
point or you know big on the dynamic I
know train yeah everyone all aboard Dino
train I remember when I first was taught
about dinosaurs elementary school and I
thought you know wow what a cool thing
but I was more interested in the the
excavation of fossils and the discovery
of you know this species or different
species that once existed I was never
really into dinosaurs as they were I
don't know what I liked about Jurassic
Park though was the just how well the
film sort of brought them to life and I
thought that was really interesting that
was pretty cool
no you know I've never actually finished
the lost world is that one look or the
movie the movie I've tried watching it a
few times I've gotten through Jurassic
Park 3 a few times though because it's
basically like one but they're like hey
so the island is kind of still going Oh
secretly been keeping our experiments up
but yeah she went wrong so we're gonna
go back and fix it we got to go back but
no it's still still pretty effed up yeah
andris bark why did we even come back to
Darwin Oh box office car this part is
like he's not a nimble dude so it's just
kind of finicky and this was that like
thing with Genesis game they're like
like
no I'm gonna make it I'm gonna live damn
it can you not go to like the left of
the right we know that those yellow
warning okay so you were a genesis kid
growing up then boom can you tell by the
fact that I knew that dinosaur was
coming back up at me yes totally Genesis
kid oh my god I was just as kid that I
like never got any new games so what I
would do is go over my friends house who
had a Super Nintendo yeah and be a part
time Super Nintendo Kid was your friend
like one of these like gets a lot of
games or or is like a super renter No so
it's actually like crap
his family was really into like pop
culture and entertainment because his
mom is like a comic book artist who like
dabbled in like horror film memorabilia
collecting and so she was really into
like all medium of you know
entertainment so video games are one of
them and so she would not buy him a lot
of games but would achensee know would
get him a game that she heard was
supposed to be interesting would be
interested in like acquiring new ones
yeah for the household yeah look at
these little bastards jumping look
that's not cool buddy rude give you a
little extra extra one of those guys
yeah I there was a period of time where
I like I would just go to video pros the
local rental store and rent so like
games every weekend yeah for y all know
I tried to do a lot of renting but my
brother was like nine years older than
me mm-hmm and he would just rent
whatever the hell he wanted Rick so what
was that like did your interests often
overlap or was he just like let me rent
the new no I would like to I the games
he would get I was interested in but
they were so [ __ ] hard that I
couldn't do anything so I would I would
inevitably play die a few times limbs
and give it to him and watch um pretend
like somehow I was involved in what you
do sure you're a spectator yeah I mean
obviously as we could see spectating
video games is the thing is totally a
thing that you know
now you don't have to rely on an older
sibling to do this guy's probably gonna
collide when I get back around but I
click oh he was right in the middle of
whatever it was he was doing hello come
here step into my office
Wow I think that's like their breathing
in coffee like vaporization favorite
copy right now
oh man that should give me some extra
protein or something I feel like there's
a raptor around here or something like
that all right which way which way up
down I don't know oh yeah he's still
sleeping up there oh yeah all right
concussion grenades that's cool so like
what yeah you know you mentioned Peter
earlier that they like animation style
being similar to something else you in
alien 3 million three years like what is
the the motivation like they're trying
to oh he came back fine what they're
like trying to make it look more
realistic like these are still sprites
right they're still spread it's
obviously yeah but were they screwed up
where Prince of Persia succeeded was
that Prince of Persia use rotoscoping is
where you take actual film footage and
you sort of draw a frame by frame you
create sprites over that footage and
that game was so fluid on any platform
that came out on games like this I mean
I feel like they they just did it all by
hand which is cool but yeah it's we're
gonna mix of like real not real you know
like it's cartoony it's a 16-bit video
game but they're trying to make it seem
realistic yeah and I think that
I mean it has to be fun right now should
be gritty like unison you know that's
really a 'td or was it an r-rated movie
uh yeah yeah I think so
maybe not I mean or with me I've had
Jeff Goldblum's bare chest so maybe
that's adult that's a sexual situation
for you right there even today
whenever that comes out crappy gas and
ILO's if only Nedry had a gas grenade
instead of a Barbasol cream can maybe
he'd be alive today stealing company
proprietary DNA
all right boom in your face
Oh what you're spitting through there as
some people are asking we are using an
emulator but I do own the game check it
Genesis card Genesis video signal is
really weird and it's kind of hard to to
capture without a few different pieces
of equipment so there's the easiest way
to do it there you go and this was in
the in the day of like proper oh no oh
whoa sorry this is a bad scene so he's
only got that one move feel like I can
send him away go away t-rex by blowing
up his face a bunch or maybe this is the
one that I just go by now I think this
one I just sneak by I think I have like
wasted and tire just wait do I have to
like make our t-rex has ever just at
rest so where they always witches I
don't even know like if if am i hitting
multiple switches before here which one
to Mike I don't even know man I dude I
don't fun
maybe the manual has something to say
about switches yeah
all right I feel like there is just
gonna start chucking these
oh man this game is filled with a nerve
shredding action according to the book
are you nervous okay nerves are getting
a little frayed I got a [ __ ] there's a
huge are you stranded in t-rex territory
and I miss manuals like real man was
that not like warning this game will
give you a seizure also things yeah what
just happened I don't know what just
happened I just I just boldly ran Bojan
favors the bold he who dares wins Peter
alright now this is a really difficult
part which was the rafting so you like
are basically falling down a elaborate
system of waterfalls and you have to
like turn the raft at the right points
so that you don't fall off the
waterfalls that will kill you but
instead fall down the waterfalls it will
like get you to a lower stage of
waterfall okay so so in other words good
luck yeah like you can turn around
you can throw flash grenades
I think I'm not supposed to go down
either of these yeah how do you even
know ah
I can hop out and like yeah so like
there's a t-rex down there
obviously I don't want to go over there
look at what he's stuck down there yeah
so he's like he's like in a cave and
found some sort of sewer grate it was
like cool so mad so anggee look at him
that thing is gonna chomp the crap out
of me or I'm just gonna go buy it and be
totally unperturbed all right of
watching max we'll play this the other
day and he reminded me I think that yeah
like this one you have to reverse oh
because if you go all the way to the
left there you're bone but there's no
like indicator of how much of gas I had
yeah you keep picking up gas but it
doesn't say well maybe it's that green
meter that's my that's your health yeah
all right Oh
every Raptors weak spot it's a giant
claw that dr. Sam Neill uses to terrify
children I think I'm supposed to jump
out here nope I don't think I'm supposed
to do that I was there's another thing
there this was not supposed to get
devoured a hole and then I had oh I hope
you guys enjoyed that because I did that
for you for you I did it on purpose I
wanted you to see what it was like yeah
eaten up not this time although Genesis
games if you play as a given
what other Genesis games that plays
guitar let's see I played I mean I
played a lot of Sonic and Sonic - yeah I
played pirates gold like so Israel yeah
how's my favorite Genesis game ever
that's the that Sid Meier's pirates
basically come to console I played the
crap out of that I played some sports
games like fifa and NHL 94 ed John
Madden football so everything okay John
Madden football yeah or like Madden 90
something no I think it was John net so
yeah that was the first one that was one
I
yeah I just love that game and all my
friends get the new one and they're
really excited that was fine but there
was nothing home original no didn't have
you know ambulances wouldn't come on the
field maybe maybe they didn't have the
NFL Players Association license yeah so
then I played you know I played like oh
I played sports talk football yes Joe
Montana and just played with the Detroit
Lions all the time because Barry Sanders
was totally overpowered get it it's fine
what does happen huh I fell into the
river because I didn't jump into the
boat that was docked yeah
seemed alright that's fine fine being a
human sucks anyways rap his widow
Raptors where it's that oh oh make good
progress thank you yeah you know I done
the password there's one of those things
it's one of those things where you like
play these old games you find yourself
having this like bizarre memory for them
alright here's this the rap the Raptors
back story's a little different if the
Raptor gets out and then wants to murder
everyone
receptacle a table your grant that
mother [ __ ] listen this is then there
was that guy with the white hat he's a
tourist here but man did he really get
my coat
kept looking at me right do you mean
that I huh holding one of these claws
alright Raptor controls like gee alright
jump super jump
can you wrapped you can pounce pounce is
like oh man
is there a chomp at that pounce yeah
there is yeah there's also a pill is it
kill this is the straight-up bite like
you could if I didn't not the copy out I
could eat it for health yeah
oh it was really cool how aren't that I
think that there was a guy over here not
for long you can also eat turkey legs or
human leg or whatever whatever it
creature like that these casual stance
these dudes are just killing one of them
staring directly into a wall staring at
the back of that guy's head it's a magic
eye man look you get Scott off you gotta
focus see these other dinosaurs don't
respect that you were like the real bad
eh in this situation I'm just gonna put
my itching my face near some chicken and
then okay yeah this is a raptor job he
opens his mouth and then this is a
raptor super jump would you just hold up
yeah yeah
how I got not hold oh my ass tease me
oh I wrapped her ass is getting real
trapped by all these yeah there you go
he doesn't eat up a tiny amount of
Turkey no just attacking look there's
dr. grant I can smell him oh my god
about to get killed by this deluxe org
I gotta get out of the flow were you big
into Dinah's as a kid he's super big
into dinos man I had those big I've seen
them around so they must have been like
a thing but like these big like hard
plastic dinosaurs that were about this
tall I was play with them outside
they're like all-weather outside like
you can't break them you can't like
damage them in any way significantly so
they felt like really hefty and you
could also like swing them against each
other like the rocks and I'm like all
sorts of stuff so my backyard was like
had like the slope down the side yard
into the back and I was like before like
water conservation was the thing I
really knew about wow I shouldn't really
pay attention I was like turn on that
the hose and let it flood my backyard
anyway like Jurassic swamp back there
dinosaurs bring it awesome yeah I get a
Monica there was like a weird yellow
puddle be that mr. t yeah that's that's
the gravy mess didn't care about you why
am I even fighting it was my natural
enmity towards man we've wakened me for
my years long slumber
I'm continuously impressed by that
hi this super job yeah or in your
ability to manipulate boxes yeah now
there's a little help boost you're part
of me now
I'm not even sure why these boxes are in
here I don't figure a rapper needs it at
all I think they're just to be
consistent with the dr. grant situation
Raptor hungry see like animation not
quite right
this thing's gonna get real cheeky with
me now I'm gonna have to chase it and
it's gonna like actually take off more
health and it's worth oh yeah this is
not going well alright I suppose you
can't like oh you can sprint I didn't I
forgot about that arms are like they're
almost like insects ah yeah they're like
crumpled up spider legs let me kill a
spider seriously way to go unfortunately
you can't feed on those guys corpses
they just disappear and that dude has
like a tiny hoozy the truth rockets for
some reason
I can't be bothered to love Soros can't
be bothered calmly walking to my
destination getting minorly rocketed in
the chest do not be alarmed by the
Raptor what's the deal rubbers Raptors
cannot swim and to avoid the water that
floods the abandoned pump station as you
pursue grants yeah where'd that water I
mean this go just standing in a tube oh
crap filled with sewage yeah he's just
he's this ankle deep in sewage whatever
minute don't judge he doesn't need to be
standing two feet to the left or right
all right oh don't go to sleep do you
think this thing will wake up you know
that Turkey yeah it did wake up eat it
nom nom oh no why did he sprint Chris
Raptors can't swim they can't apparently
sprit to their deaths don't you tease me
come on I know you're comfy here yeah
crap get it I would run off screen too
if I were you fair enough fair enough
little dinosaur absorb turkey with face
it's the Raptor way is it even fun at
this oh there you go
Raptors love sewage I losing health
because oh yeah got just so good
nope don't run them this is a no running
zone no what what are what are all of
you doing here get on my belly
come over here come over here and get in
my belly mama
oh no oh that's fine it was fine it
worked out okay everything's cool it's
all good oh I fell off a ledge I'm proud
of that good if you know there I was
running late we need to find some turkey
but man they just expect you in the
palace I think a the bells of the go-to
yeah cuz it they really do expect you to
do like this I mean what net what
recourse do I have here I mean I guess I
can see that there when there was never
touched it
all right and then you're screwed to go
down around let's see why is everyone
dying in front of me right do you think
I can go straight down yeah Wow
no is that this is the ledge I'm on a
very tiny you sure that's like these
like it is that that's water Dan yeah I
think I can bounce oh damn you Jurassic
Park Wow
alright temper codes alright let's code
it up no one asked for it and you're
getting it by barrel I love that all
right
uh yeah alright we're gonna go to a
quick ad break so we can keep this show
running stay tuned we'll be right back
more Jurassic Park codes and we're back
Hey trying to figure out some codes here
we're gonna try to skip to level five
try doing a eight and then thrown in tu
at the end eight at the top all right
yeah
vvvv tu oh man this is a this bow goats
come on game Paks
alright try eight you got the V's to try
you won at the end
all right where are you taking me PETA
look at the eyes bug out in the rearview
mirror
it's pretty common it's like the toy he
just got the toy of the big dinosaur
and from here you will have to travel
overland through the canyon alright it
looks like we got past the river then
there was some level in between some red
level
now we're going overland to the canyon
I'm music what's my weapons situation oh
I got like max all this stuff you do
even this dope rocket rocket some dope
all right I think I've made it this
level like once holy [ __ ] look even the
Raptor it is just dead I can't handle
this volcano man yeah right you're gonna
wake up oh what Oh what
I thought I'd tag that one is it in
their nature to do that it's just you're
the Dino expert to play dead yeah yeah I
don't know I don't think Raptors play
dead although they may be they are
hunting in a pack Wow alright cool up
this move in herds
okay that's not shooting out of the sky
look at that lava in the background
what's there a volcano in Jurassic Park
nope in the book yeah let's go flinch oh
man alright a little copy they gonna
start some stuff I'm just gonna use my
way too powerful for you darts on you
come on coop why didn't you grab those
oh you know what
this is the tricky [ __ ] about this level
you don't need those darts though no
I'll check it out though I'm pretty sure
Oh what I thought that that was a thing
Wow okay it is it thing sees me the
grenades okay I'm out of here
nope not that's just a copy spawn point
now the wrong things are commenting on
you so I was pooping on you man guys
raining turds what the hell
listen man life with dinos is no joke I
mean it is a it's a poop joke thanks
really pickle real bad poop joke look at
that that's sleeping raptor is taking
shits I'll never fall that framerate I
like real slow stupid guy promise
I can kind of look down but I have a bad
feeling about Hall little monster tricky
little daemon ducking out of my rocket
attack this soundtrack sir sighs this
they couldn't found a better composer
for like a big property like Jurassic
Park this is a pretty weak Oh what dude
no all right were you cool
not even any sidelines anymore I kind of
want to just blind jump to the right do
this game makes it ooh ooh oh no sorry
all a small distance I broke my ankles
even more than they were already broken
apparently
rocking it to sit on it and grouse
predicting and I mean movement Fedders
except for that one I got that one right
in the face and it wasn't till I was an
adult that I realized when Fonzie was
telling mrs. C to sit on it it was like
oh really rude Wow Fonz that is
inappropriate yeah I'm pretty sure no
one said that in the 50s
ah yep see like his spit can spit cannot
can stop your projectiles but you can't
stop the spit just turn around
oh damn Chris this is our level Peter I
told you it was hard all right I got one
life to live I'm gonna live it damn you
you'll just stay asleep if I can't know
games like pre grenade him absolutely
not enough god yeah I know you're down
there okay oh you can't make it so now
they would have refused this hell it's a
flash grenade not a gas grenade go to
bed also YouTube go to bed together you
know have a little love in this
prehistoric hellscape all right cool I'm
crawling under the rocks so there's no
way a pterodactyl could ever attack me
anymore it's probably a true thing right
I wouldn't get this game too much credit
Tara oh dude it's punishing
I should have pre grenade it just pre
load a grenade on that thing's face
it's Moody don't you understand about
mood don't get in my face little friend
oh dude oh it's eating me hard-on for
you man they have it damn it damn it
brick
all right this company's gonna get it
just pure revenge I should hug okay okay
not gonna eat them you should either get
real Savage I don't know what you're
gonna do about this guy can you throw
the gas grenade and maybe just anywhere
it'll put him to sleep or the flash just
distract him that you know you're gonna
just do the blind Joe Oh God
yep definitely it was a bad idea to do
that all right we're putting new code
new code new code you have no choice
it gets me every time it's the little
things all right ah a five V's you three
a vvvvv you three what how did that get
in there yeah maybe it was like updating
it for my firm playthrough
ah the days of entering codes that you
know where could you get these magazines
a lot of magazine yes it didn't like a
like Tips & Tricks magazine like a Sega
visions I meani up that one I'm not
gonna lie man I was on CompuServe and
prodigy back in the day and they were
bulletin boards that had codes for these
games
No
it was the thing active volcano blocks
your path to safety in the visitor
center I will say this Mortal Kombat
when we rented that on the Genesis to
get the blood code due to Blockbuster
actually told us oh nice
that is a good customer service yeah so
you're in space now right I'm getting
look I can't shoot that thing but he can
shoot me yeah game design 101 break all
the rules
I don't think that actually does
anything bad Oh dump all over the prison
no jump I didn't make it like you're
supposed to do like just go forward once
you say I'm supposed to come back to
this nope that's the first 20 meters
like in a this game alright different
level because what nothing let's play
some Dino DNA it wasn't done some Dino
code that's a final level with the
Raptor oh sure man or just some level
with the Raptor it says the password is
just open park type open park yeah okay
actual word passwords from what a
thought alright
my cat gives me a look every time I feed
her follow grass does she make that uh
huh yeah haha that's Tara Islands Tara
I'm scared of my cat another sound
tractus well yeah cuz it's a boss battle
against grant or something I don't know
I'm walking on the lake and I know spine
just a dino spine up there it's called
an exhibit it's called an exhibit please
don't jump on it it's not finished yet
that's the whole game fact just straight
up jump kick everything I was I went
against my rules
Raptors can't open doors no stymied by a
door just jump it's more than one screen
height it's huge
alright let's eat some chicken that's
cool now I don't know what to do
like there's some trick to opening in
the door yeah
lead Raptors can open doors that's the
whole thing yeah but all right how do
you do it though he whipped with your
tail take a look with your tail tail
whip
maybe if I kick this table which has VHS
tapes books and a yeah a like an Xbox on
it
yeah maybe a panasonic 3do alright Rob
alright just cool it just super jump a
little bit all over the place
alright the wrappers gone berserk yeah
okay there we know anyone in the chat
you guys have any advice here we're
touring stuff you need a backtrack a
little bit how we're paying attention to
the chat now apparently the rapture oh
we can only open kitchen doors oh of
course
because how foolish yeah of me because
you know the movie right the movie man
and these box there's too many boxes
these aren't the pushing kind of boxes
remember when I could push boxes or
earlier
hello friend I will gently caress you
with a claw and nothing will happen you
look good in that turkey all right yeah
this is one thing I'm tenacious about
it's turkey everyday is Thanksgiving
when you're a raptor mostly because the
people who make Jurassic Park got a real
bulk deal on turkey legs
Costco is having a Black Friday sale on
turkey legs
all right I know man isn't it for you
like we're like a minute ago yes it is
there's not a lot of degrees that I do
at this point
wait what was that what was that move
like I did that see that move I feel
like I did it what was that oh we like
to turn yeah what did what was that how
did I do that is it like an extended
animation are you taking your finger off
the man Oh opt open the door tight Thank
You Chad it's the same friggin animation
Oh God yeah thanks jack
oh the benzene right here no don't worry
about a guy it's cool Oh oh yeah
boom oh yeah legit dyno tactics what
didn't you punch me I believe in your
Raptor as much as I believe in any
dinosaur it's not working very well but
don't worry now I know how to open those
any turkey oh that's
goosed I don't know getting hit in the
butthole the Rockets all getting goose
but I like it yeah you didn't see
nothing I want that dude to go mess with
the guard yeah well yeah how come the
guards aren't fighting with other dinos
they're all just against you no one
likes a rapper yeah that's the lesson
this game has taught me yeah the Raptor
terrifies everybody eat an equal measure
Raptor brings other enemies together
yeah it's just a little try to kill you
yikes
these guys are packing more of a punch I
need some food fortunate there's some
turkey down here by these tower CPUs and
also a box it's me
Wow my man hello I is a bunch of food up
there though some incopy forum southern
turkey for him alright
what listen that copy was just standing
there placidly and thus eroding my soul
wow you know what I'm saying with this
game Peter well yeah Estelle jabón for
sure but like not not that great
actually oh dude Oh I mean vexing yeah I
encountered that phenomena in a regular
basis yeah not even on this show but
like I buy a lot of old games and part
of it is for nostalgia purposes part of
its for you know personal preservation
purposes but only about half the time
everything are you like oh I'm glad that
I have this back yeah wrapped you're
opening the door but to be fair though
for the bunch of this game isn't so
great in practice the look on your face
and on Mary's face when I brought into
the office was worth the five dollars
you guys a really [ __ ] star so happy
so thrilled to see this game again even
though I probably never got to this
level I can feel you feel Peters
disappointment in me
50 different
oh yeah what's up
oh but literally a rocket in one
all right let's farts let's send this
one out with just the ending we can just
watch the ending just want to straight
watch the ending straight-up ending it
yeah you ending blue sky one well we've
seen the beginning we've seen how
perilous it is in the middle it might as
well give you guys the reward that none
of us earned blue sky I'm here did they
stuck with us that's right you guys
earned it me I'm not so I I wish I had
been a little better for you guys
honestly I'm so sorry
they're gonna type in this code just got
one there you go yeah credit that's the
end here no come on
oh but that's how it was
thanks for nothing Oh Jesse
Wow Rai Heights Jesus can you imagine if
you spent all your time trying to beat
the game in this way I mean there are a
lot of games that did this to you right
mm-hmm
but give you the credits roll I mean
you've probably got like like at the
beginning right we got like a two or
three shot intro like here's the cage
here's the dinosaur face escaping the
cage you probably get at the end
something that's like like a like a
raptor here's the dinosaur there's a
dinosaur on the boat and the boats
leaving [ __ ] and I don't know we're
gonna stick with this we're gonna see
what happens after the credits oh yeah
all right yeah and because what if it's
like they're already asked special
thanks it's true this game was made by
six people and it shows lead tester
Vince Nason ha then the entirety of cig
of America say buddy not some things
slip through the cracks
let's just say that I don't know your
budget was like I don't know your
schedule is like so I'm not gonna judge
I'm just saying all these testers and
none of them found that bug with the
vine
maybe it's not a bug yeah they're all
it's just one of those things that's
aimed it's like indistinguishable from a
bug so you feel like you're getting
cheated as a player but you're not
actually because that's the way they
designed it I feel cheated as a player
right now you are using cheats oh right
I had it coming the whole dad checks out
yeah all right that makes sense all
right well thanks for sticking with us
everyone that is Jurassic Park a good
game for the Genesis is certainly a
slice of history definitely a game yeah
certainly well we'll be back next week
with more megabit not sure what we're
gonna play just yet but I'll let you
guys know on Twitter but meanwhile video
game History Month is coming up in May
starting Thursday this week we are gonna
have a lot of classic gaming related
content on the site so stay tuned I'll
be putting a lot of stuff out on Twitter
PC Brown Chris waters you are CT waa TT
er s damn nice work yeah yeah and come
back at 2 o'clock today playing some
four player co-op on multiple players
and if you see multiple players before
you know that we're not that good at
cooperating no gonna be fun all right
thanks for watching minute everyone take
care happy Monday